you said something while talking about
this she said i wanted to do something
that allowed me to be at home mm-hmm let
me be at home work from home yeah and
chill and then you said because i quit
acting i just stopped right
um
it's been a conversation
for so many it's been a a wonder a why
why did cameron diaz step away from the
world of acting what is it that
motivated you
to stop well you know i think you
probably can relate to this it's like
when you do something at a really high
level for a long period of time
you know you're there there's a lot that
when you're the person who's sort of
delivering on this one thing right
you're the person on the screen you're
the person who's like the talent you
know
um
everything around you
all parts of you
that isn't that has to be sort of handed
off to other people
you know so like different parts of my
life whether it was my home or
every aspect from finances to just the
management of just me as a human being
not me as cameron diaz because
cameron diaz is a machine but like for
my personal person my personal
spiritual
you know self
um i
was realizing that you know it's kind of
like that that one part of me that
functioned at a high level wasn't enough
you know it's fun to do i love it i love
acting it's you know i can
go forever i literally feel like
sometimes i have unlimited you know
energy and
you know inertia
you know i mean
like movement forward like you know you
know i don't know i'm gonna ask you yeah
i know i love that yeah i'm not feeling
any bad i don't feel a certain type of
way no so judge me later but i don't
know i have no judgment okay that's not
i don't give a [ __ ]
i understand so you
you know just like putting that forward
and i just realized that i looked around
and it was just like so many parts of my
life that i didn't have i wasn't
touching and that i wasn't managing and
i couldn't really manage it because it
was so
it was so big everything was so
you know massive how how old were you at
the time when you're getting this
realization i'm like 40. mm-hmm and it's
clicking at this point in a way that it
never has yeah and i wasn't you know i
didn't have you know i have a lot of
great friends and i have a lot of really
incredible people who have supported me
for so long and who and i really do
believe it's about the people that you
have you know in your life that can help
you keep things moving and i had some
amazing people and had other people who
were not serving my best interest always
but
you don't have time to figure those
things out
if you are just going going going going
like this you know with blinders on you
you're you're you're in the tunnel
you're in the tunnel i'm very familiar
with the tunnel yes right and yeah and
as that machine that you're referring to
is getting fed because like you said
there's so many people around you but
they're just feeding the machine they're
not that concerned or interested with
the person yeah you know well my i i
feel like i was really lucky because i
had people that i worked with for 20
years you know i mean who i really i
know they have my best interest but for
me i just really wanted to make my life
manageable by me you know like my
routine in a day is literally what i can
manage to do by myself i know it has to
feel amazing it's the best going from
that yeah i feel whole and like and i
also didn't have you know i didn't have
the
uh you know i found i met my husband you
know we started a family all of those
things that i didn't have time for
before and didn't actually not just not
have the time for but didn't have the
space to make the decisions the right
decisions for me at the times to bring
that in so i love to hear it yeah
[Music]
you